are we actually going to start for real
is this for real yeah yeah for realsies
all right okay jack you don't know this
but we start every game by doing a weird
face contest
so and then we let the audience decide
who is the best weird face because we
all have webcams
everybody ready yeah all right three two
one go
all right good job everybody whoever won
we'll know in the comments
below right now so let's go do it i
didn't do very well this time
i don't care my face hurts i really
don't care that's how you know it's
working
it wasn't worth it the tingle means it's
all right so oh that was dumbo that's
right over here underway
what there was a newspaper on the other
side of wherever and uh
yeah i was sitting right there watching
i didn't think that there was a
newspaper actually there so i'm an idiot
oh oh no okay what happened what
i became a vending machine for a second
oh
yeah the last time well there's not any
vending machines around
any machine
i'm to get it hang on wait i think
wade's going to be in the same place
no i don't know about that i don't know
my life
you don't know me
mr ken oh jesus
if i get lost i might have you to get
you to help me no no
no way know how shape or form i am are
ever going to do that
you're such a bad team player i'm the
best
i see you in there messing with those
garbage can yeah
where you going what you doing on the
chairs
who's the douche mcdoucher now you
shouldn't let on your clue
bob what is happening
i heard splashing
you go down that security door i'm gonna
go down this way
be cool all right oh you got it you go
down there
yes what yes what that's totally
unbelievable bob
jack you go down that way
right at the borderline yes you need to
move like
no you're good bob never mind you're no
you're not good you're worse
he's in some weird place isn't it no
he's not he's not yeah
wait wait i've got cookies for you if
you tell me a location
i am in a place that you have already
searched good
good and you didn't find me so he's in
here wait a minute
he's in here because that chair was not
knocked down oh oh
oh oh obviously i didn't
i wasn't that when you were in there
before i was like following you around
just so we're clear
three stooges you're the three you know
is that just your only reference to
american uh
uh novelizationism or whatever it's
called exactly
or you know what i mean uh that's that's
all american
therapy yeah american i'm not gonna do
too well
oh i'm gonna do what are you doing over
here no
no no no no no no no
you ran out of time relax
no so what's going on fellas don't blow
what the fact that you're right on the
open
mac you are illiterate okay you know
what me
they're so stupid they won't see it
coming they are incredibly stupid i do
know this about these guys
yes yes i'm betting on that these
particular goobers don't know what
they're doing most of the time
and in fact especially wade and in fact
yes where is the weak link
bob very smart very smart if he was up
here
he'd find us in a second someone already
make him
here couldn't do anything couldn't do a
damn thing at all
no a mistake where bob where
i don't know where you are i don't
either
could i be swimming around yes do you
hear split splashing
splish splash i was taking a bath that's
good singing
that'll distract him
uh i'm officially out of ideas
your decepticon no open your ears damn
it
what what do you say
you're slurping flies yeah exactly your
thirsty thighs
are you drunk no are you be honest i'm
always drunk i'm irish
yeah that seems about right that's tap
water to me we only did drunk prop on
once and people loved it and we said
we'd do it again then we never ever did
it's you it's closed
yeah doors will close by themselves
eventually wow
what the hell i don't know wait were you
moving stuff around in here
and where probably i've not really been
moving stuff
i don't think they're in the open i
think they're hey wait a minute
nope hey wait a minute mark it's working
i totally can't believe it's working
jack jack what's your jock jack
never let go no i'm not i'm not john
tran right now
there's something i'm over here jack do
you even know what i am jack
i didn't see you i didn't even know you
were here until you started yelling
well i didn't need to say that i was at
the same place as you were that's why i
was so upset
for yourself well okay well they'll
never find me i mean you're
you're you're you and i am golden i am
master of disguise
you're the master of what debating
you're a master of who
i'm a master debater you're the master
of why yeah
he's trying to say is he likes fishing i
think
um i don't understand
of course don't it's brilliant i don't
understand
you don't get it yes i don't understand
you don't get it
i don't understand that sounds perfectly
normal wait have you looked upstairs in
this uh
in the apartment or whatever this is
yeah it's where i'm at what the hell's
going on
that worked far longer than it should
have it really did you guys
i didn't even know we could go over
there over where
where you were over there over there
the police are coming underwear
what what did they did they see your mom
naked
is that real life experience no crap
i made a calculated mistake bob
i immediately regret my decision okay
jack what we're going to do
i'm going to do my thing you don't be an
idiot goodbye
we're a team no i don't think so team
oh no crap um
oh crap
oh crap uh this spot might work this
spot might work i have faith
oh no it won't
you guys know i was stuck in a trash can
as a trash can outside right in front of
you
are you silly
uh
there was nothing i could have done he
was there and i had to shoot him or else
i would have lost him okay okay i'll
trust you this once
that's what you gotta do rookie get out
of the way when you see your target you
gotta shoot first and last question
you gotta shoot him in the face rock you
gotta clean his [ __ ]
you gotta
yeah you gotta give them the old one too
wait this looks weird
what looks weird no okay what was weird
about that rookie
wait keep your head on your shoulder
wait are you still alive
bob and i can't tell what you are wade
is very dead i shot him in the face
i'm going to just cook some watermelons
you're going to cook
boil babies over there and i'm going to
go upstairs
oh watermelon baby what
you can't even see it watermelon baby
wait
how did that just happen what what
happened why did what happened
wait a minute i'm just gonna go out on a
limb here and just
what the hell is that you where are you
is that you bob no there's nothing
oh it's not there anymore yeah i saw
that though
oh
going to win this without being able to
move is that about yeah you're going to
win this because they've got no clue
where you are
oh wait a minute there's a shooter
everything that's not you
wait a minute what let me let me give
you a hint let me give you a hint
huh okay you've already you've already
shot and killed one of what i am
what what what did you kill you didn't
kill anything up a pacifist
what did we shoot it with a gun i don't
know
grenades i'm out of grenades i can't
shoot anything else it's just bullets
just okay so it wasn't upstairs it's
nice
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no it is upstairs though
don't be such a quickie oh my god no
don't come upstairs don't come upstairs
he's not upstairs he's out there he's
not if he's lying he's a liar i don't
understand maybe he is upstairs you know
you guys haven't been in the sewer yet
yes we have don't lie to us we have been
in sewer you're
watermelon bob i thought you were the
whole thing oh
i told you i should have made watermelon
you said you were gonna boil watermelon
babies and i thought that you had that
taken care of and
instead i finally stopped yelling at me
i don't want to yell at you i didn't
mean to oh you guys
okay that was a mistake oh no
mark it's enormous oh no i can't
thank you oh crap hola oh my god
oh god oh god
what did you do i didn't do anything
that's the problem
you stole my idea you doof you don't
even know what my idea was
oh i am so dead no one will know
no no
i'm going to be okay
as long as i stay perfectly still and
i'm gonna be okay so long as
no one finds me and shoots me in the
face that'll be okay as long as you
don't point out where i am
where are you i don't even know where
you are where is he he's over where are
you
where is where is everything bob where's
life look where i'm pointed follow my
voice
where is shut up wade it was clever
oh no still had the bottle above your
head
i did mark no
no wait come to the sewers no
no no wait no you don't know no you have
no clue
no i have a heart trapped in a corner no
you don't
hey wait wait are you coming or what
it's a dirty line you don't have to talk
no all right let's go outside and do
this like a man
come on dude come on i would rather not
here i'll ride you you take me outside
okay let's go
if you promise that i'll be okay yeah no
i'm gonna
kill you if you just take me outside i'm
gonna calmly go up the ladder
i'm gonna take the ladder
i'm going to offer you i'm going to
offer you okay ten
thousand subscribers if you guys can let
me live i
i take it if i ever let me live if you
let me live i'm
very independently wealthy in terms of
subscribers
okay and there's no way yeah
any of that i don't like bribery and
i'll get fired
gonna give you 50 000 if you shot weight
but you're too late no oh oh that's too
bad
yeah you i don't think subscribers work
the way you think they do oh you don't
know that
you don't know that you're new to the
secret there's a secret system
yeah how do you think he got to where he
is yeah exactly i just sucked it out of
everyone else
literally oh crap oh crap
okay that means he's boned oh god oh no
oh bad things are happening not
good this door is still open that door
open you go in there i want to close the
door behind you you have fun in there
okay
please no hey hey let's see where
it is i'll show you where wait is i'll
sell them out oh we're waiting
i'll sell them out oh i think he would
have done that was you
yeah oh
let me end your torment just tell me
just talk me through this situation
squiggle will slowly wait wait just
relax just relax let it happen just
wiggle
wiggle wiggle wiggle wiggle
wiggle wiggle wiggle wiggle wiggle oh
can you read it
oh my god i see the little shadow of the
meat puppets cockroach thing that you
are
oh man wiggle for me wait do the wiggle
worms please help me wiggle worm yeah
wiggle
no wiggle more it hurts wiggle
keep wiggling i'm trying not good enough
nice where's all this happening oh you
missed it it was uh not important you
don't need to worry about that he's
perfectly fine back there don't ignore
the screams
nothing spectacular
hey bob i'm licking your face right now
ew
that you said you keep doing that for
like 20 more seconds jack that's a big
compliment in ireland land i thought
that was a scottish
condition i don't know i am golden like
a potato
oh you guys are boned what's a golden
potato it's a
glorious thing that you americans
wouldn't know you're right i don't know
about us this one you haven't had the
glorious
irish potatoes well i'm good i'm good
forever
no one will ever know all right how are
you over here
what's going on over here nothing you
don't see a damn thing
hey jake get away from me you're a
communist or something
oh what the hell secret powers yeah
you tell him jackson catch gingerbread
man yeah oh my god what a glitchy
[ __ ] ladder
you run away from him jack get him rock
get him rock
show them a thing or two give him the
old one too no don't what are you doing
rock no what the hell you got to be an
independent you got to be
i got it just keep going
you got to clean this easter egg you got
to suck him up
you got to pay off the ref you're not
strong you got no upper body you got no
legs
what the heck is happening there's no
way it went wrong
actually rock was italian not not not
ironic
wasn't mickey rourke um uh wasn't he's
irish
no that's mickey mouse you're thinking
of him okay yeah sorry michael
you gotta clean his [ __ ] clean his hot
there right
i think that's the wrong mickey mouse oh
all you got to do is stroke him up and
down ha ha
ha ha give him the old one two one two
one
brushes oh god mickey minnie
how many minnie is that you is that you
minnie okay we lost i have a cigarette
now
i cannot believe this is working jack by
the way i do what i tell you
die together yeah i mean i mean i mean
stick together
okay we're fine okay you be minnie
i'll be mickey why am i the girl bob
will be goofy
and we're gonna have a little little
action here oh my god
it'd be goofy wait okay you're goofy but
if you're a bad goofy we're gonna get
rid of you
wait be goofy
oh gosh goofy that'll be 50 bucks
oh forget you mickey no
that's terrible that's that is literally
the worst goofy i've ever heard
ruining my childhood weight oh we ruined
everyone's side i'm much better at
mickey than i am a goofy
do it wait wait i don't understand
what's happening
yeah i don't understand either where are
they i don't know
but they're not down in the wall yeah
they're not
down in the well
no they're not well enough no they're
not
well enough hey wait i got mark horner
again
no i'm dead oh you died i mean what do
you mean you gotta be coordinated i'm
very dead
oh i i had a corner and then i showed
you the face but you'll
never further what you point blank range
shot him in the face never find jack
i am a sneaky sneak he's a sneaky
irishman
i don't like sneaky very well
do it come find me hiding by the
riverside
oh you're not by the riverside you're
actually far away oh yes
by the riverside mark
dot s applier don't you dare
mark s player mark s that's your real
name isn't it oh
mark soccer mark your second name is
player isn't it yes
actually yeah yeah welsh name thank you
not gonna fall for it this time weighty
boy yeah exactly hey that's my scottish
name
i'm close to winning right now i don't
understand
of course you don't it's brilliant jack
sings it is also traditional to give
hints in this situation
i expect you to i'm gonna die oh you are
so dumb you guys are dumb
look where they're gonna get any kind of
queen
right now yes uh-oh
high five right virtual i5 high five
your webcam waiting
stay out i was not ready can you okay
high five right now okay on three three
two one go
did you do it no did leave me hanging
yes
god damn it thank you all so much for
watching check out bob wade
and jack's channel in the description
below if you want more prop on let us
know we're going to record something
else after this so thanks again
everybody
say bye everybody bye everybody
okay at the wall